brock set us up with corbin burns
outstanding year last year he made 12
appearances nine of them starts i mean
a nifty 211 earned run average power
pitcher
in every way and there he gets a
strikeout he just do it right down the
middle
[Applause]
one and two the count
bouncing ball nice easy hop for colton
wong
and two that are out for corbin byrne
and that one's in the air deep left
field gonna hang up got it jammed and
yellets will make the play burns through
his first inning
one two three jose mourinho twins are
gonna need him to be equally as good
especially looking how his mount
counterpart started off this game
first pitch lifted
behind third a rise
in foul ground makes the cap go away
line weakly to first and cenote of the
bag four pitches two outs
pitching was the question mark it
actually ended up being the other way
around
what happened with the twins last year
too
a breaking ball on the dirt a strikeout
for burritos in each starting pitcher
off to a good start here tonight in game
two here we go to the second inning
and he's gone
and a swing and a miss gonna have to
secure it at first narvaez
gets himself an angle and
secures the strikeout here's a 2-2
and he's gone he got him
got another lefty-looking cave
with a backwards k
four strikeouts he strikes out the side
in the second inning does corbin burns
will face hiro bradley and kane
blow him away with heat second strikeout
for barrios
now the changeup down the middle gets
the swing of the miss
good to see that velo from brio's early
my goodness
this could be fun to watch if you like
well-pitched games both burns and
[Music]
did he go he did and it's another
strikeout
man
fielders
are not necessary right now the one-two
got him and simmons won't bother narvaez
secures it anyway
and the strikeout binge continues
and there he goes got him that time
the run of strikeouts continues 10
straight for both teams burns has six in
a row
ball put in play a rise
on the run makes a nice play
cutting toward the line running to his
right and then throwing across his body
on target
great speed yep big power big speed and
sometimes has a difficult time making
contact burns has him on the ropes two
and two of the count trying to put him
away here
and he does another strikeout for burns
corbin burns
on his a-game these guys have been
beyond
what we advertise they're both good and
young
jack swing
strike three
and barrios
has a strikeout and that's his fifth six
excuse me
and a call third strike a get me over
breaking ball for strike three
seven strikeouts for blurrillos
did he go
strike three this is a joy to watch
four perfect innings for barrios and
burns each with eight strikeouts
burns back to work pitchers are the
headliners right now
bouncing ball out to wong the shift is
on
and one way for
corbin burns here in the fifth inning as
kepler is retired
sono
pops it up a mile high
cold wong is back in the grass
and there is out number two it is all of
a sudden putting the bat on the baseball
they had been making good contact
and that hit him i think it did
first base runner of the game 26
consecutive batters retired to start a
game
burns a long pause and a swing at a miss
he struck him out
hits a batter comes right back picks up
strikeout number nine
carrios and burns are cruising barrios
has been perfect through four innings he
has eight strikeouts
the brewers get their first runner on a
hit batter
same way the twins
put a runner aboard
wow
bradley
swings somewhere in the vicinity of that
breaking ball for strike three
to center and boston hardly has to move
two away
a pitcher's duel
a dual no hitter
between burrills
and burns
dueling no hitters corbin burns and jose
barrios
the minnesota twins what a game burns
back at it
right back to the mound nice and easy
for burns he'll underhand flip it to
hira out number one
co2
got him
well he got him
in swing mode and then got him swinging
for strikeout number 10. dale pitch with
two outs
and downey goes
97 on the black
corbin burns with 11 strikeouts see for
reals five no hit in him giving up just
one hit batter second base sweeping
breaking ball
gets a strikeout number 10 for barrios
in play
long and bad for
burns
but he puts the ball in play out number
two
and a breaking ball got him for
strikeout number 12.
six no hit innings for both starting
pitchers corbin burns six no hit innings
one down buckstone for two the 1-1 pitch
is swinging a fly ball right center
field deep back it goes deep it goes and
gone buxton homers to right center and
the twins take a one-nothing lead
no hitter gone shut out gone byron
buxton homers for the second time in as
many days and that'll be the last pitch
that burns throws that's a shame he
walks out here with a run on the board
and down one nothing it's a standing
ovation jose barrios is done for the
night for real six innings no runs no
hits no walks 12 strikeouts
pitch count at 84 bringing on taylor
rogers for the second time this year
strike three called on a backdoor slider
and down goes riaz one out
deals home to one two strike three
called at 96 yellett strikes out for the
third time tonight
two out 14 strikeouts now between
barrios and rogers pitch he got him
strike three fastball by him swinging at
95. so rogers comes in looks like
barrios and strikes out the side now the
twins have runners at the corners with
two out and it's going to be up to luis
adais ground ball up the middle and
through bases center field simmons
scores stopping at second cruise auris
delivers a two out run scoring single
and the twins take a two-nothing lead
tyler duffy new pitcher out of the
minnesota bullpen first goal is to
deliver a hit omar narvaez
representing the tying run down the
right field line that's down
fair ball into the corner it goes
kane will stop at third now
will hold it first
and there is action here in the eighth
there you go in the hit column and the
twins attempt at no hitting milwaukee is
denied yet again pinch hitter coming up
billy mckinney so the wheels in motion
swinging a fly ball into right field
kepler there to make the catch and
that's out number three
alex coleman suffered a blown save in
his twins debut looking for save number
one tonight
well the brewers down to their last out
with yellets coming up
where's they're hoping to
strike here as buckner the umpire matter
of fact they caught both the catcher and
the umpire on that foul ball
that one bit him and hit off the thigh
of jeffers and then right under the mask
throw to the neck collarbone whatever cb
buckner is in
a whole lot of pain discomfort right now
as he is squatting down hands on his
head oh no dave yeager the brewers
athletic trainer is
has collapsed goodness oh my goodness
very scary situation here right i mean
i'm glad he's walking off under his own
power c.b buckner is going to remain in
the game as well so let's reset it for
you here two outs brewers down two
nothing swinging a pop-up
foul territory behind the plate over
near the third base dugout playable for
a rise he's got it on the warning track
and that is out number three
the twins win the game coleman one two
three ninth
and the twins are one and one after
defeating milwaukee
two-nothing the final score